why is this important now why are we
gonna do why are we telling my wheat
this is it
I mean it's legal right it's all illegal
okay how does that work do people get
upset at you if you do certain things
that's me non-muslim right that's him
so the dilemma is this alcohol is
prohibited in Islam that's clear-cut
right yeah alcohol is actually killing
people it's it's killing people and it's
prohibited in Islam what are the top
three arguments that you have dealt with
[Music]
welcome back to the detail how you guys
doing how are you doing doing excellent
so I'm leaving that why they come with
solo I heard you're training a lot now
I'm the great Gracie jiu-jitsu trying to
keep it up yeah you're getting ready for
your friendly match for Joe Rogan
getting ready has he contacted you the
last program not yet we've been waiting
because you guys are right there in the
same community aren't you yes and that
we're both doing jujitsu
okay well let's kick it off since we
mentioned Joe and we did that nice show
for Joe on some of the misconceptions
that people have and you kind of went
systematically one by one we dismantled
those arguments but we got something new
now that we're going to touch upon for
all the weed pot smokers marijuana dope
smokers yeah yeah I think this is gonna
be very interesting let's get into a
clip how's that let's do it because he
recently he had what's at Elon Musk what
happened with that so he brings Elon
Musk on he you know offers him to try
marijuana you know smoke something he
takes like you know he smokes a little
bit and all of a sudden Tesla stock
drops like significantly because of one
move of Elon Musk no wow yeah at which
which shows you that you know people's
perception in society of marijuana is
still you know it's still concerning
they're very concerned about doing that
this is it
I mean it's legal right so legal okay
how does that work do people get upset
at you if you do certain things let's
meet on Muslims right that's him
he's the owner of Tesla owner of Tessio
of classical marijuana is wonderful
first turned on to it by Charlie Murphy
and then reignited by Dave Chappelle
okay plus whiskey haha exactly perfect
balances it out and some whiskey huh
alcohol is a drug that's been
grandfathered in well it's not just a
drug it's a drug that gets a bad rap
because you just have a little it's
great well we could smell a lot on that
why is this important now why are we
gonna do why we tell my weed okay
marijuana cannabis was the proper turn
any of these yeah marijuana you can use
cannabis so mayor marijuana is the main
term you know and so many terms and you
know maryjane dope you know weed all of
that stuff it's really important right
now specifically because you know we
grew up in a generation where there's
like the you know where the dairy
program drug abuse resistance education
we're taught like don't do drugs at the
same time you got pop culture you got
movies you got media everyone is
promoting marijuana
you got Snoop Dogg you got dr. Dre you
got you know all of these people have
been promoting marijuana for a long time
so there's this mixed message being
given to people that you know what drugs
are bad for you but then at the same
time you know marijuana's not that bad
it's not gonna have so many effects on
you it's not such a big deal so we got
legalization of marijuana across several
states in the United States we got now
legalization of marijuana in Canada for
recreational use as well in Canada right
now in Canada the new largest that's
just not medical you know in California
it's medical right California it was
medical we were the first state to pass
medical 1996 or 1998 but since this year
January 2018 it's it's just completely
legal now you can do recreation you guys
where you should walk right into a
marijuana dispensary I did it just for
research purposes not tried it but
walked in there and you don't need a
card you don't need a medical caught you
don't need anything
walk in since this is beginning of this
year how old do you have to be what's
there I think it's 21 21
I think it's 21 but anyone who's 21 can
just buy it and just go and give it to
whoever 13 year old 12 year old and now
Canada the whole country the whole
country it's legal for recreation as far
as I recall yeah
okay yeah yeah so this is this is a big
thing so what's happening is spreading
and what it shows you is you got almost
30 states where it's it's legal for
medical or medicinal you know purposes
and usually there's some basis for that
but then that's also a flimsy excuse for
people to go and just have easy access
to marijuana you know you could go in
there I mean my brother told me a story
he said he walked in in California he
had a backache his friend said you know
what why don't you you know go get a
marijuana card he walks in 30 seconds
there's a doctor on skype and he goes
what's your problem so I have some back
pain he goes oh okay how bad is it
it hurts quite a bit okay giving you a
prescription for medical marijuana
that's it he's got his card he can buy
now as much as he wants he didn't buy it
but he just got it you know and he's
like it was a joke it was like literally
a joke so we got that dilemma of people
now having easy access to marijuana it's
seen as like it's a safe drug there's no
problem you can get high you got Muslims
now who have always wanted to smoke like
having more of an excuse of you know I
don't drink alcohol but this one is okay
but then on the flip side you actually
have you know medical advantages to the
cannabis plant and it's very hard to
differentiate between these two people
are confused about well where do you
draw the line where is it you know there
for your medical benefit because there's
a lot of there are benefits in the
cannabis plant so that's where we have a
problem now yeah how do you balance that
out because alcohol for sure there's no
doubt about it I mean and we don't just
go off this we have the criteria we have
the Quran we have the Sunnah everything
you just clearly laid out yeah but now
when you look at for instance who the
World Health Organization they estimate
that every 10 seconds or is it one in
every ten people no one every ten
seconds someone is dying from from
alcohol mm-hmm right yep in every 10
seconds someone is dying from from
alcohol but you don't have those same
kind of negative effects with with
marijuana exists then it you also have
some medicinal
value there exactly so you see that's
the dilemma so here's the and that's the
argument to so the dilemma is this
alcohol is prohibited in Islam that's
clear-cut right yeah alcohol is actually
killing people it's it's killing people
and it's prohibited in Islam yeah
getting high for recreational purposes
on marijuana or any other drug is also
prohibited in Islam that's a clear is
there there is no doubt about that
there's no arguing
there is no re it's recreational
recreational use any drug
any drug that's going to be altering
your mind it's a psychoactive drug is
going to it's it's prohibited in its
life wisdom now the wisdom let me tell
you the dilemma first the dilemma is
that the argument in American society
and in many Western societies or many
parts of the world is say but alcohol is
legal and marijuana is less harmful than
alcohol so it should also be legal so
what Muslims start doing is they're like
they make the same argument they're like
well marijuana is a lot less harmful
than alcohol so they buy into the same
thing and say okay well it should be
that should be halal whereas what you
know we believe that alcohol should be
Haram that part is clear so there's
confusion there right and the confusion
is easily resolved for Muslims in
differentiating between the two so you
got alcohol may be more harmful than
marijuana but they both alter your state
of mind right so in Islam alcohol is not
only prohibited because you're gonna
potentially go home and you know beat up
your family or because you're gonna get
a DUI right that's not the reason why
it's prohibited that's one of the
wisdoms but the underlying reason why
it's prohibited is because you're taking
your mind your your freewill that Allah
has given you and you're basically
altering it so that you cannot make the
same type of rational decisions when
you're in a state of you know being high
when something is altered your state of
mind anything that's gonna alter your
state of mind is going to be prohibited
in Islam that's why alcohol is
prohibited even if you didn't have the
stats on DUIs even if we didn't have the
stats on you know causing liver you know
disease and all of these other things
alcohol would still be prohibited in
Islam
because Allah has given you this ability
to think straight and when you try to
take that away and you start making
irrational decisions even if they're not
necessarily harming anyone you start
laughing at jokes that that are not
really funny or you know you start
saying strange things or whatever it is
islam teaches us not to put ourselves in
that type of state anything that's gonna
get us in that state we need to stay
away from it that's why alcohol is
prohibited and on top of that all of
these other bad things happen because of
that marijuana is in the same category
what are the top three arguments that
you have dealt with okay regarding
Muslims or whoever and they want to use
it as a recreational drug yes top three
arguments argument number one is it's
not the most common but the first one
that comes to mind is that you know
there's verses in the Quran where Allah
says that you know he created all plants
you know and this is all natural so
because it's natural Allah created its
built-in nature all of these plants are
there why can't we consume it it seems
like it's perfectly fine a problem with
that argument is I mean you could
poisonous mushrooms you know or in
nature as well you're not going to
consume them you're not gonna eat things
which are which are harmful for you so
that's that's a problematic argument
right the second argument is that it's
much safer than alcohol so it doesn't
cause the same level of harm as alcohol
and that's kind of what I was explaining
is that Islam did not prohibit alcohol
only because of the massive harms that
it has for society but it prohibited
altering your state of mind because
you're not gonna make straight thinking
decisions right and the third argument
is that you know what when you say
intoxication anything that intoxicates
you right then they say all caffeine
should be prohibited
right because it intoxicates you
nicotine should be prohibited they say
you know eating a lot of chocolate
should be prohibited because it alters
your state of mind that's really a
semantic argument that you know caffeine
you know can intoxicated caffeine when
we say intoxication any anything that
causes intoxication is prohibited in
Islam unless there's some like absolute
necessity for it that's a play on words
it's a trick of words because
intoxication has many different meanings
intoxication in Islam basically means
anything that is going to alter your
state of mind such that you can't think
straight the way you would when you're
not on that substance you can't you know
you can't speak straight the way you
would normally do compared to when
you're on that substance so that's the
problem so I've heard that argument a
lot they're like well if you're gonna
say that you know marijuana is
prohibited then caffeine should be
prohibited and then other things should
be prohibited or they talk about you
know it's not addictive like alcohol or
it's not addictive like other drugs so
then the assumption is that the reason
why it's prohibited in Islam is because
other drugs are addictive and this one
is not addictive but that's not the
reason that's not the underlying
reasoning so we need to differentiate
between the effects on society which are
there there's no doubt I would argue
that III agree and Muslim scholars would
agree that in many cases marijuana is
safer than alcohol but that doesn't mean
that it's okay to do right and from an
Islamic perspective right so that's a
challenge that society has to deal with
and there's a famous Imam Imam Qaddafi
he lived about you know eight hundred
years ago in Egypt he made the same
argument he was actually arguing that
hashish is potentially safer than
alcohol you think both are prohibited in
Islam but he was making the argument
that I sheesh
if someone takes her she hashish is from
the cannabis plant as well it's from the
resin of the plant whereas marijuana is
from the flowers of the plant so it's
very similar it gets you intoxicated the
same way gets you a little bit high and
all that but he's saying that when
people consume hashish they're not going
in like you know getting into fights
becoming violent and all of that like
you do on alcohol so this is not some
new argument Muslim scholars have been
tackling this for a very long time but
that's where there's a confusion in the
mind of people that they can't
differentiate between you know massive
harm to society versus you on an
individual level should not alter your
state of mind because it's not a good
thing to do it's not good for you and
that's what our creator has taught us
so this is what you specialize in this
is your you're also from the California
Islamic University University yes so
this is your Olson and Imam yes your
specialize in these areas yes so I've
been doing a lot of research I just
wrote a paper for the fig council of
North America on this we just did a
paper for California Islamic University
as well so that's something I've been
researching for a long time now and I've
had a chance to really look at into this
in detail and I'll tell you honestly
like researching this has changed my
perspective a lot not on the Islamic
prohibition of recreational smoking or
inhaling or whatever but more on the
medical side so my research has actually
concluded that you know there's a lot of
benefit medical benefits in cannabis and
this is something that Muslim scholars
have been saying for over a thousand
years they've been saying they've been
saying that I mean there's some scholars
have been saying that there are medical
absolutely not recreational not
recreational recreational 100 percent
clear-cut not a single Muslim scholar
thought history that I know of has ever
said you can just you know dig it up and
light it up a joint know like we just
saw Elon Musk and your bacon do you like
one of those no you can't do one of
those okay right it can't be like Joe he
can't be like Joe it can't be like Elon
even you know just trying it be like
that's not so bad it's not so harmful
given to the argument about you know
it's safer than alcohol and all that all
of these arguments we may agree with
these arguments but just because
something is safer than something else
doesn't mean it's good for you yeah so
you can can you say then can you say
that one of the wisdoms that the creator
had created this plant is it's there
because you wonder like then why did he
create it why is it there hmm can this
be for one of those for that healing
absent that in the plant absolutely yeah
absolutely not because there's there's
it makes sense there's so many plants
out there where if you use them in the
correct proportion they're a healing for
you they can be used as a medicine and
there's a hadith of the Prophet peace be
upon him where someone came and said you
no prophet should we should be used
medicine and he goes yes use medicine
because there's not there's not any
illness
that Allah is created except that he's
created a cure for it meaning you just
gotta go find it yeah you know except
death so can you make it another example
let's say the pig mmm now if you had a
farm and I'll connect it to this where
that pig is like a human garbage
disposal it just eats everything all
right would you be able to say a law
created it you know as a garbage
disposal and I can use it on my farm to
eat up all the garbage got it yeah yeah
not to eat it not to eat it yeah not to
eat it but maybe it serves another
pressors another person came here with
the woodies plant exactly exactly
because i've seen i've also experiencing
family members who've had the cancer and
you just start to look at because
traditional medicine are the traditional
drugs they they many of them come at a
huge cost they don't actually heal
mm-hmm and but then you have a healing
component in this and you have people
testing that Opa Opa addiction you know
major epidemic you know how many people
are addicted to opiates you know you've
got a huge problem especially I mean in
in in the high schools we have you know
kids especially from upper-class
families they're all you know pop in you
know different opiates yeah you know
that they got from their parents and
they're addicted
how would you that sort of painkillers
the painkillers who needs them to meth
to leads them to so many other issues
they have a ton of documentaries
exposing this the kid or the adult goes
to the hospital and they put him on
these painkillers and then they finally
they leave the hospital but they still
they're addicted No
yeah and then they end up when you
interview them on the street how did you
get here I started off with yeah opiates
with the opiates with the painkillers
and now he lost his whole life his whole
career he's he's on the street now she's
on the street because of he that's a
huge epidemic of a problem absolutely
yeah absolutely have a dilemma now you
have these drugs that come at a cost
they're not and in many cases they're
actually they're making more problems
exactly like this is just one exactly
that so many side effects right so and
that that's the problem so so that's one
of the common arguments for the
legalization of marijuana is that it's a
lot safer than these other painkillers
and other prescription drugs that are
there which are causing so many other
problems and it's a legitimate argument
right I have like a warning at the end
but
is legitimate are even so let's talk a
little bit about that right so the
cannabis plant is what marijuana is you
know used to it's made from cannabis
plant
okay cannabis is a plant and it contains
two main chemicals it's got a hundred
chemicals but two main chemicals one of
them is THC okay it's tetra hydro
cannabinol and then you got CBD which is
kind of video so most young people they
know these terms they know THC and CBD
THC is psychoactive okay THC makes you
high okay CBD actually doesn't make you
high it's not psychoactive and now the
latest research shows that CBD inhibits
THC so the more CBD you have the less
effect that the THC is gonna have the
less high you're gonna get if you go to
any medical marijuana dispensary you
look at their menu okay they have a menu
of like different types of weed and what
you could buy and all that strawberry
cush and different you know strains
they're trying to maximize the THC
content and minimize the CBD content so
THC content gets up to like 20% or more
CBD content gets below 1%
it's like point something percent right
so that's because people want to get
high they want different types of high
when they're gonna smoke it or vape it
or you know use a bong or whatever now
what's happening is that the latest
research on medical marijuana is showing
that it's most of the healing properties
are in CBD they're not in the THC so if
you want the medical benefits of
marijuana for most illnesses now it's
showing that high CBD strains of
marijuana or high CBD products are the
ones that give that benefit which is
perfect for Muslims because we're trying
to avoid the high THC so that we don't
get high we don't alter our mind and yet
at the same time we get the medical
benefits of marijuana I for me this is
like this is amazing like this research
is perfectly in line with Islam because
Allah created this plant
people have been abusing this plant with
hashish and they be using this plant
with mirror abusing it with marijuana
and then we see the medical benefits and
now research is showing that most of the
medical benefits they're actually in the
part of the plant where it's not gonna
make you high in the first place and
that's amazing
that's why we should be promoting more
research in that field the problem that
we have is the federal government of the
United States still classifies marijuana
or cannabis is a Schedule one drug which
means that they believe it is very
dangerous and it has absolutely no
medical benefits that's a federal
government not on the state level yeah
right so what's happened is you can't
until recently you can't grow cannabis
anywhere you can't grow it you can't
have it you can't import it you can't
get it anywhere you can't test it so
there's no medical research being done
so all you do is you have a few people
you know trying here and they're saying
oh look this helped me this helped me
there the research cannot even continue
and that's a problem right so that's why
from the Islamic perspective we would
like to see more research being done and
we should be promoting the research on
the cannabis plant to see what kind of
you know more medical benefits that it
can actually have and it's a much better
alternative than the other drugs that
are out there on the market now since
it's legal in the whole country of
Canada is this going to promote more
research or the hope is that it will
absolutely yeah and it's a good thing so
so this is where Muslims have a dilemma
are people now also allowed to grow it
and in their backyard as they grow
tomato or different different
regulations exists so I think I think
it's state-by-state they have different
regulations so I'm not I don't know the
details of that but now people can
actually grow it on a more massive level
for the last thirty years they could not
even grow hemp hemp is from cannabis it
doesn't produce marijuana it's used to
make like fibers and all of that and we
used to import all of our hemp from
France because you know the government
was so afraid that anyone's gonna grow
any cannabis plant you're not even
allowed to grow a hemp plant which has
like almost no THC in it right so so so
now that's all changing and there's
gonna be a lot more research coming out
and and we should promote that research
and that's good
going back to your point you're making a
point the dilemma the dilemma is this so
what we got is the people who are
pushing for the promotion of medical
cannabis or medical marijuana as they
say right for medical benefits they also
believe in the
pushing the recreational use of
marijuana and making it just accessible
there's nothing wrong with it
Elon Musk Joe Rogan it's not a not a
problem just smoke out whenever you feel
like it and it's not a big deal so
what's happening is you got these two
things overlapping people who want it to
be used for recreational purpose and say
there's no big deal and also to be used
for medical purposes they're kind of on
the same boat and that's where Muslims
have a dilemma Muslims need to have a
clear line in between that on the one
side you got you got the okay for
medical purposes you know of using
cannabis but you have a clear no when it
comes to recreational purposes right and
when the two become mixed a lot of
Muslims become confused and they start
doing the same thing right they start
thinking you know what there's no line
in between and that that's the problem
that's the challenge how do you now
what's the what is that line that you
have okay I have a backache
and I know where what line does Islam
give ya you to where you can take it and
where it's crossing it because someone
has a legitimate back pain legitimate
you know neck pain whatever the case
right now they have to decide am I gonna
take this ibuprofen I'm gonna take this
but you know a painkiller yeah that it
comes at a cost
so actually messing up the lining in the
gut and in other health problems over
time or no I do I go ahead and take this
marijuana because usually which we think
okay if someone has cancer then there's
no doubt about it
okay take it but where is the line I'll
give two general principles so the first
principle is that if you got if you got
a high CBD product it's not gonna get
you high because it has very little THC
or or maybe even no THC in there so when
you have a high CBD product it's not
gonna make you high
so yeah so high CBD product is not a
problem at all right it's not a problem
because not gonna make you high so
anytime you have an issue with pain or
whatever it is using a high CBD product
if it can't make you high if it cannot
be psychoactive it's not gonna get you
in an altered state of mind there's no
problem with using it at all all right
under any circumstances when it comes to
some products some products have to
a little bit more THC those can
potentially get you a little bit high
right you can only take something that's
gonna get high as a medical exception in
Islam so the the exception has three
rules rule number one
there should be no alternative available
that does the you know the same thing
for you like safe alternative available
number two it's got to be proven and
effective that actually works right and
number three you should only take the
amount that you need for that
significant thing and it should be an
illness that's significantly affecting
your life these are pretty much the
principles that Muslims need to apply
people usually think about when you
think about cannabis that you're getting
how you're smoking it but you've
actually you have people you know they
turn it into an oil mm-hmm and it looks
like black oil yeah there's some there's
there's oils
there's edibles there's you know there's
so many ways of consuming it I think one
of the issues that we have as Muslims or
as a society is that there's there's
something connected with smoking in and
of itself that like if you're smoking it
it's bad because people generally smoke
tobacco and they smoke marijuana too you
know for bad purposes so we've connected
smoking as being like the problematic
route it's not necessarily problematic
there's some lung issues and all that
but if you vape it if you consume it to
an edible if you take it as an oil
there's so many different ways you could
apply it as a topical there's creams you
could put if you have jaw pain or
something you could put it on your jaw
certain illnesses and all that there's
different ways to actually get it in
into your system as long as it's a safe
route of getting it in whether it's with
the oil that you were mentioning and
almond oil cannabis oil CBD oil is very
popular and there's two types of CBD oil
there's the hemp oil which has almost no
THC and then there's CBD oil with a
level of THC but like a ratio could be
like twenty to one or forty to one CBD
versus THC content right that stuff as
long as you don't take like an excessive
amount it's not gonna make you high and
it has a lot of medical benefits and a
lot of this research is coming out it's
proven a lot of people have you know
been cured from a lot of illnesses
they've been able to manage a lot of
their pain and you
there's room for that in Islam and we
shouldn't you know we're concerned about
abuse of this product it's a real
genuine concern but we should also be
concerned about what other people are
going through these painkiller addiction
people are going through pain and Islam
allows and promotes the use of medicine
for these things Allah has created this
for that purpose are pretty much the
scholars in this area are they pretty
much on board with the same conclusions
that you're talking about so I think
most scholars don't really understand
the cannabis plant they don't really
understand the difference between THC
and CBD nor have they seen you know the
medical benefits of this I think if most
scholars did see it they would really
change their perception so you know I
wrote this paper recently for the
council of North America when I
presented my findings to the scholars on
that council all of them were like this
is really you know this is some good
stuff
I had one [ __ ] right after the next week
he called me and he goes so what ratio
of CBD to THC oil should I get because I
got this other problem he's like I'm
going to the store and I'm buying it you
know like I'm going right now because I
have such-and-such illness and I've been
researching and it looks like the CBD
oil is actually gonna help me in this it
is way safer than the other medicine so
once people even the scholars like they
have the foundational knowledge of Islam
but they don't have the knowledge of
exactly what's going on with the whole
cannabis plant and CBD and THC and all
that once they learn I think most
scholars will be on board with this
opinion because a lot of people are
waking up when you look at the the
pharmaceutical industry and you look at
the many people don't even you know many
doctors don't even consider though that
medicine they consider it drugs you know
you're masking the symptoms you're not
going for the route but here you have
potential that you can actually fix the
problem
and again we're making it clear you made
it this is not recreational light up a
joint in my basement and get high
exactly that that's clear in Islam
there's no that makes sense no altering
of your mind exactly where of your
surroundings what you're doing that's
the major point here we're talking about
making it clear this is for sickness for
medical use exactly yeah legitimate
legitimate medical use
and there's there's where that
flexibility is so many people are
weighing out you know the here I'm
taking this you've had some there's so
many cases you know when you look at
let's say you pop this drug you know and
then you have next thing you know over
time you develop all these other
problems you know next you know got a
lump growing here cancer tumor you know
and and this is this is just people are
smart people are waking up so they're
looking for more of a natural means that
and and this is a door that now a
discussion that's that's worth taking
what do you happy I think it's
definitely where do you recommend for
someone to get because we just kind of
touched upon it where do you suggest
someone what role because you don't you
can't you don't just go to your normal
medical doctor he doesn't know much
about it yeah just stayed sir right it's
it's starting to change I mean from
California so it's starting to change in
California now there's some regulations
that are changing so people are gonna
start prescribing it and recommending it
more there are actually some drugs that
they produced from you know CBD and THC
mixtures that are that are now approved
by the FDA so it is changing I would
recommend unfortunately there's not that
many you know great resources that I can
you know refer you to but if you just do
your research primarily on high CBD
strains and just talk look at the
medical benefits of CBD or high CBD
strains of cannabis that are consumed in
different ways and what type of
illnesses it can help for you can find a
lot of that you got to be a little bit
careful when you're treating yourself
because sometimes people don't really
know exactly how much they're taking
this is not a regulation on exactly how
much you take and all that consult your
medical professional who is well-versed
and has done their own research on
cannabis and then you know you can
consider some of these alternatives a
couple more points I want to mention
before we conclude if you notice Elon
Musk is a very successful entrepreneur
he gets around Joe Rogan and just the
importance of being around good company
and good friends yes I don't think this
is something he's not really a marijuana
smoker right now some pressure gets put
on you you know and you're on the spot
yeah I can see what influence I was
thinking about this
I said wow man how powerful it is what
kind of people you're hanging around
with absolutely that plays a really big
role and we got to really be careful you
know because one of the things that
happens with people who smoke marijuana
is they actually create like a culture a
very tight culture among people who get
high right so when you kind of walk into
that group they want you to be part of
that group and once you become part of
that group it just reinforces the
behavior and you keep on doing it more
and more you try and rationalize it you
try and justify it it's safer than this
it's safer than that it's the safest
drug out there it's not such a big deal
the effects will wear off long term you
know harms are not proven all of these
other arguments will come but at the end
of the day it all comes back down to
shewe or desire people have a desire to
just kind of escape from the problems
that they have and they're just like you
know what man that's what that's why
people drink you know they go to a bar
there you have a bad day they're having
problems in their family the boss is
giving them a problem I just want to
escape this world for a little while
people do the same thing with marijuana
they want to just escape you know but
the thing is you don't escape by
altering your mind something that's
gonna harm you it's gonna harm your mind
even if it's for the short-term you
don't try and escape that way there's
other ways to deal with stress other
ways to deal with challenges that Islam
has given us you know Aslam makes us
understand that we take life seriously
that we have a purpose in life and I
encourage people to watch their company
and try and figure out other ways rather
than just trying to escape from their
problems by getting high or getting
drunk try and find other beneficial you
know you know positive ways that they
can deal with that martial arts would be
one of them exercise would be another
you know being in good company sometimes
you just talking to your friends making
dhikr praying just sit in the Masjid all
of these things actually bring peace and
solace to your heart help you deal with
the challenges you're going through this
is something you're also trying to get
motivation amongst many of the community
leaders to start training also you start
training the graces use it so yes some
that I've been advocating for so long
yes so you started yeah I started it's
I've been doing martial arts for a very
long time different ones but now I've
really got into the Gracie Jiu Jitsu I
really recommend it for a lot of people
you know people who
want to just learn basic self-defense
techniques one it develops more
discipline and organization in their
lives they want to get a little bit
healthier you know there's so many
benefits to something like there's a lot
of people they do gym and they workout
and all that but I think this is really
important as well because it gives you
it gives you more than just exercise it
gives you exercise it gives you stress
relief it gives you life skills it gives
you you know just so many benefits and I
think it's it's it should be part and
parcel of Islam Muslims should try to
you know cultivate this in their life
these skills these benefits into some
aspects of their life and the last thing
we have some good news and this goes
back to when you're filling the void
that every human being because you
mentioned purpose of life and when you
truly I mean all of us even when you
found that you live it you still go
through trials and tribulations but when
you just numb yourself so many of these
things you don't sometimes it's hard to
embrace the challenges but when you have
your connection to Allah to your Creator
you know you where other people they
climb that ladder and which each and
every step they see that that void is
still not filled it's never gonna be
fish a Nate O'Connor for instance she
was like the Michael Jackson the woman
of her time very famous woman she was
someone who recently just accepted Islam
and you can see someone like that for
instance may Allah give her success in
the Deen and keep her steadfast it's a
great example of going and looking for
peace and contentment in all the wrong
places drugs being one of them getting
doped up and high and you know suicidal
but then you find it in the deen you
want to be aware unconscious that's
that's the best place to find it you
know as so many celebrities they they
took their own lives they went into
drugs they went into all these things
because they were searching for
something and and they went down the
wrong path hamdulillah you know sister
Sinead O'Connor now hamdullah she's
Muslim she went down the right path she
could have gone into drugs she could
have gone into doing all sorts of you
know other weird behavior because of the
challenges that she was facing in life
but hamdulillah praise be to Allah that
she chose this path instead and you know
we're very happy that she came and and
we're praying for her and we hope we can
help her
this path you know what the the number
one suicide bridge is I think it's in
your neck of the woods over there that
bridge yeah it yeah it might be in
Northern California is it where is it
the gold is in Golden Gate Bridge yeah
that's one of the number suicide not
surprising yeah in the world in the
world yeah yeah so now that is amazing
now that she hummed Allah Allah so and
Allah has guided her and to the purpose
of life and as we encourage a lot of
people to really look look deep into
themselves and to seek and to understand
pick good friendship and this is just
one relevant topic that we're talking
about but it all comes back to at the
end of the day who what's your focus is
in life when you're connected to your
creator the final call is there is that
how it should be absolutely how do we
ending with that like at the end
do I want to please myself and my
desires my you know am I am I going to
the quite qualified paper and at the end
of the day what's my guiding light yeah
exactly
we gotta realize our life is bigger than
us this world is not just about us we
have a purpose here so we have to always
keep that in mind at the end of the day
yeah we have free will
yeah we could do you know its limited
free will we could choose whatever we
want to do but we are accountable at the
end of the day and we're gonna have to
answer for how we lived our life you
know so sometimes we need to sometimes
become so individualistic so selfish we
just think about you know I can do
whatever I want and no one can stop me
but in the end of the day when you die
you know there's some teachers that
there's gonna be another life and that
you weren't created here just like in
vain just to kind of play around and
stuff there's a reason why you're here
and if you realize that if you
understand that and it's kind of
intuitive that there's some
responsibility you got to take in your
life and that's where people just need
to be careful they need to realize that
they're gonna be held accountable for
what they did in this life so they
should take their life seriously and not
take it as a joke thank you very much is
Oklahoma
always a pleasure like lakum song and
thank you guys for tuning in if you
haven't subscribed subscribe already hit
the notification bow and
this is very important that we don't
waste the time that we've given given
been given here in this life every
second that we are here it's a blessing
every breath we take we get closer to
our appointment with death so life has
meaning make it meaningful by living the
purpose that you've been created to live
and if you've testified now Allah Allah
Allah Muhammad Rasul Allah that is your
guiding light fuel it not your desires
we'll see you next time until then peace
be with you
Salaam alaikum subscribe to the video
follow us on our official Facebook and
Twitter pages in the links below
please also help support the V show by
making a donation in the link below
[Music]